the 15-time nascar most popular driver
Dale Earnhardt jr. trades in his helmet
for a microphone as he joins the big
boys NBCSN team for the Monster Energy
Cup Series race from Chicagoland
Speedway Sunday 2:30 Eastern on NBC
fresh haircut new dad looking clean
ready to go good to have you
yeah it's good to be back here man how
would you do as a taxi driver
you know I'm New York City I was just
thinking about that I wouldn't it would
be an adjustment you know because it
seems like that people change lanes here
a lot of that looking don't they do that
in NASCAR yeah you know it's just so you
know there's there's like this I don't
know you just know where everything is
without looking where it is you know and
you do that on the racetrack but I was
watching people driving in from the
airport and they're just turning
changing lanes and not really taking a
look around as far as if they're clear
or not and they don't have spotters like
we do so I think it'd be pretty tough
but I think I could adjust to it who
would you want to be in the taxi with if
you could have somebody drive you if I
could pick who could drive me yeah you
know somebody who's driven in New York
City and either the taxi drivers in New
York know I'm talking about NASCAR
driver I know I would rather be more
confident in them because they're used
to the environment Jimmy you know
Jimmy's got you know had a place in New
York City who knows there's a town a
little bit knows where he's going Jeff
Gordon had a place in New York as well
yeah I enjoy being around Jimmy a little
a little bit more than welcome I don't
know just older and he's kind of like my
elder where Jimmy and me are kind of
pals but Jeff - your dad would be like
hanging out with my best friend versus
maybe my uncle okay that kind of thing
okay but the age difference between you
and Jeff Gordon is what I don't even
know maybe four years oh that's not a
lot I know but he got started oh that's
so young he was very young things like
he's been around forever okay when
you're walking the streets of New York
what do you get what what do people say
to you just I might get recognized a
little bit just junior hey junior what's
up yeah
Jr I just hear jr. over and over you
know everywhere well in New Yorkers
don't have time yeah like they're not
saying you know let me stop and I got a
story for ya now there's no stories it's
just you get a you'll hear your name and
look around and a lot of times you don't
even see the person they've already gone
into whatever door they were going into
they just disappear you jr. and you look
back and there's no one there yes yeah
where can you not go if I said the worst
place for Dale jr. to go socially I mean
if I wanted to you know at going around
the racetrack you know and that's
obvious but if you're at the racetrack
and and you want to go if there's a
concert playing or a band you like or
something like that I mean you got to
know what you're getting yourself into
a lot of guys like to ride around in the
in fields particularly it tracks like
Talladega and so forth where the the
party atmosphere in there is legendary
and you know you just got to know what
you're putting where you're putting
yourself into there and be ready for
that mentally but I don't really I don't
really get bothered that much by people
saying hey man good job or you know I
always always like that interaction
especially when I raced because it made
me feel like what I was doing was
valuable you know being a race car
driver and doing well on the track and
when people would say hey man good job
you ever have a bad experience with a
fan oh yeah I mean there's fans that
don't like you you know and especially I
mean it's on social media it happens all
time if you want to go looking for it
you know where you can find it but a lot
of times at the racetrack when we're
riding around on during intros during
drivers intros so we get introduced on
this stage we walk across stage when
they throw us in the back of these
trucks and they parade us around the
whole racetrack to wave at everybody
there's fans that are not waving are you
getting flipped over yeah lots of lots
of birds I just let you just laugh
because of the passion you know the deck
guys like you know what when he comes by
he's getting the bird
you've never flipped anybody off have
you yeah other racers you know you flip
off other racecar drivers
the Bush brothers probably pretty much a
lot I mean a lot of people but it's sort
of a you know flipping off another
driver on the racetrack it's kind of a
bad deal we you know I don't know why
but the bird really racecar drivers you
can do all kinds of other things but
don't flip somebody all of them off they
come see you jr. is part of NBC Sports
celebrating the fourth season of Monster
Energy NASCAR Cup Series and that'll be
contributing in the booth there is a
race analyst and that'll be Chicagoland
Speedway this Sunday July 1st at 2:30
Eastern on NBC
SM yeah you're doing big-boy stuff here
out of the car into the booth new dad
yeah a lot of things going on I know I'm
right we wrote a book so we got a book
coming out later this year in October
called racing to the finish and about my
concussions and retirement and all that
Eila is two months old and every day
with her has been amazing she just
started smiling so yeah I mean it's like
it's incredible so now all I do is try
to make her smile now that she's doing
that everything's like smile what do you
do you know I did be goofy make noises
she just got to where her eyes are
working where she can track objects and
stuff so we had a lot of noisemakers and
any you know it's really not that hard
to get her to smile and but it's become
a little bit of a competition between me
and Amy who she smiles at the most and
which is fun for us that's just been a
really really cool experience we're
already talking about you know hopefully
trying to expand our family
oh yeah well I'm 43 and were you ready
for this at a younger age yeah well no
no but who is you know I mean you know
that those type of things have a way of
maturing you super fast and and forcing
you to change your lifestyle and and in
the way you think but I really am
frustrated with myself that I didn't do
this sooner that I didn't get married
sooner that I didn't have children
sooner I know I had a lot of fun in my
20s and in my 30s but you know I'm
I realize now how great these
experiences are and you know frankly I
wish I could have started sooner and
enjoyed those at a younger age but
people will try to tell you what it's
going to be like yeah like oh you know
once you have your baby this is and it
it doesn't matter what they tell you it
doesn't live up to what that experience
is so I could have told you having had
four kids oh yeah this is what its gonna
be like right I'm a brand-new father and
I don't even waste my time trying to
explain it to my friends who are who are
in the situation where they're their
wives are just you know just now
pregnant or they're thinking about you
know getting married and things like I
don't even you can't really prepare
somebody for it because I thought I knew
how I was gonna be how I was gonna act
you know and and they melt you girls and
melt you I know and she's not even
really in her you know we're not really
even engaging that much with each other
no way to here dad oh man yeah I can't I
can't wait I can't wait for those things
imagine if you were still driving though
could you could you still be driving 30
weeks out of the year away from home it
makes me worse you know it makes me kind
of respect the guys that do race and
still you know and raise kids on the
road and and juggle all those
responsibilities it would be hard
because I'd want to be with her and I
and I wouldn't be able to be with her
I'd have to go to the racetrack and be
away from my family away from my wife
so that would be very challenging to do
you know luckily in a situation to where
I told NBC I said you know I really like
to stay home if I could as much as
possible so they gave me the whole month
of May I literally did nothing you know
and so it's uh it's been a it's major
have a hobby yeah like me and tricks on
some property where he's a huge deer
hunter and I'm into it a little bit you
know outside of that I don't think I
have mini-golf
no no no I got a simulator at home and
I'm just like you know you guys have any
other shoe i play on that have a lot of
fun but I'm not gonna go play outside
and where you know it's everybody I've
ever played with it I grade the hell out
of them how bad
was so I just I remember playing with
Steve Letarte one time and he barked at
me and we louder than he ever did when I
drove the race car he was mad at you
because of golf not driving I picked up
a gimme I hit the pin on the second on
the second shot on a par four and I
missed the shot for birdie and I went to
hit it again actually and he was mad
that I didn't pick up the gimme he's
like that's a gimme don't miss this
third fourth shot you know you had a
shot at birdie he was so mad at me do
you can you fix cars yeah I used to work
in a dealership well you worked that's a
did you change the oil requirement when
you have a job at a dealership you fit
you changed oil yeah I did every job
actually I started changing oil I've
worked on the I ended up getting
promoted to assistant engine guys so the
head engine guys this older fella a lot
of experience and I would if he got a
[ __ ] job or a engine job I would pull
the transmission and pull the motor and
he'd put it back in put the new one back
in so I had a lot of jobs around there
before IV sleeve was let go did they
know who did what would your nametag say
junior I don't Dale junior Oh death but
did they know dad on the dealership oh
did they ever ask for autograph when
they would come around you know and he
would be there and I worked there for
like 3 or 4 years my brother was working
there as a service writer he was a
mechanic and then got promoted to
service writing and one day we got a new
service manager and the guy was like
we're gonna stay after and we're gonna
have this meeting I'm gonna change his
service department and fix it and I was
like well I'm not staying if we can't
stay on the clock so he said you know do
whatever you think right so I went home
cuz he wasn't gonna let us stay on the
clock and so I came back the next day
and he goes I think you need to take a
couple days off and see if this job
really matters to you and so long story
short I ended up getting fired from the
[Laughter]
dad ok with you getting yeah I called
I was broke you know I didn't have a lot
of money and it was a 45-minute commute
to the dealership and and then back and
I called dad I said this guy's sending
me home to think about my job for a
couple days and see if I'm really
serious about it I don't want to drive
all the way home and then you say get
your butt back to work and nobody's
gonna front the bill on the gas that's
gonna take so he said now come on you
know actually go in there and tell the
guy that you're working or not working
and so I went back in there didn't tell
him I called my dad and I said listen
I'm gonna work or I'm not
and he said find somebody to help you
load you to that job okay but did you
were you driving competitive I was I was
I just graduated high school or college
I got an automotive degree at a
technical school in your home and and so
I'd only been out of school for a couple
what if they had kept you employed in
actually you know made you gave you a
promotion like assistant manager would
you have delayed your driving career
hopefully not I mean I you know the the
racing was happening I was still I was
starting to late miocene is better for
the the story story get fired and
because of that I decided to become a
racecar driver well like I ended up
getting fired and drove home and dad was
surprised he was like I can't believe
that guy fired you he really fired you I
was like yeah he goes Wow okay well I
put you to work
working on your sister's late model my
sister raced and said that's awesome and
I got a raise I was making about 180
bucks at the dealership ended up start
starting at dads place around three
hundred dollars a week whoa yeah I know
and I live right across the street so
I'm working on race cars it was a great
great move for me that's the next book
take your tools and go home the Dale
Earnhardt jr. story that's really what
it should have been you're right you
talk about the concussions in the book
the book is gonna be released October
16th it's racing to the finish my story
and I didn't realize that a lot of the
book has to do with the number of
concussions how it affected you you had
a scary moment a couple of years ago
here yeah there was a you know I
couldn't really talk about all this
while I was still racing I there was a
lot of reasons for that
and so I'm now feel you know I feel a
little
to be able to tell the story when I was
racing I didn't want to spend my final
season trying to tell everybody this
story and explain all the concussions
and not why I'm retiring and I just
wanted to enjoy one last year and not
let it be dominated by headlines of
concussions and and and things I had you
know maybe hid from people and and not
been you know not not shared with people
openly so finally once I got out of the
car I'm like you know what I can try to
I can try to tell this story and not
everybody's gonna be real happy with me
but hopefully it helps people understand
if they're making the same mistakes that
I made and it also shows a lot of things
man is people get these injuries and
they don't know where to go to get help
but did you drive when you shouldn't
have been driving
you know that's a yes
I should have there were times when I
got hurt that I didn't seek help and I
should have I can say that for sure well
I would like to drive with the
concussion well I would draw symptoms I
wouldn't drive with symptoms I you know
and you'll read in the book like the
symptoms would clear up by Thursday and
I'd go okay you know I'm good you know
I'm okay and I think that that's the
common that's the common you know theme
for most guys or the common reaction to
most guys is like I feel good you know
it's gone it's over I'm over it and the
problem that is the the the issue for me
was that I would continue to get hurt in
crashes that I shouldn't be getting hurt
in you know I would I would you know
bump into guys and hit walls it very
lightly or or not an accidents that
looked very bad and and I would get
injured and I would feel terrible you
know for 48 72 hours after the race I
would have symptoms and I would hope
they would go away and they would and
I'd go back and race and I would finish
great the next week
you know we'd run in a top five we'd
have a great weekend but then four or
five whatever
two months later I'd crash again and get
sick again and I basically was just
layering did you get nauseous
I had some nausea my symptoms would be
all over the board you know there's so
many there's different compartments in
the brain that are affecting each other
and they all work together and when
one's down they all kind of go down and
you'd have different types of symptoms
whether they be balance or nausea or
optical or whatever so powerful stuff
the book is gonna explain so much I you
know there's the books gonna help people
but also a lot of people that are like
man why'd you retire so soon
why did you retire this is gonna spill
all that out and hopefully give a lot of
people some some answers Dale jr. he'll
be in the booth coming up this weekend
Chicagoland Speedway did we ever tell
you the story when we were first time I
went to Chicagoland and Jimmie Johnson I
was talking to Jimmy Johnson prior to
the race right before the race I leaned
on his spoiler oh I I like I'm just like
I'm Chad canals look he wants to kill me
right and I'm just chatting with Jimmy
you know this is seconds before you guys
start the race I just got my I'll just
lean it on the spoiler there and you can
just see his crew chief was just looking
at me like if you make one move I'm
gonna snap you in half and Jimmy doesn't
say anything right and then I talked to
Jimmy after that and he knew what I was
doing but he didn't want to say anything
sure he ended up winning the race hey so
you think you had some effect on his car
I think if he you know maybe he could he
could have gotten disqualified or he
lost some points because of me because I
affected the spoiler yeah well that's
something yeah a lot of people would
lean on the spoiler that's something you
know we shouldn't lean on good that's a
very important part to cars aerodynamics
good by the way did if you had a boy
where we were we going Dale I believe so
we haven't we had a name for a boy real
early that was easy
the name for the girl was hard I wanted
a girl I was scared to have a boy
because he would you know I would be
impressionable on him and I was afraid
of being a you know have been a new
parent making a lot of mistakes and that
you know that being something my son
would have to deal with we're doing Dale
know Oh
working on deal no no okay but we had
nay we got it we had names that were in
our family that meant something to us
and so we're hanging on to that if we
have a boy we're ready okay Chicagoland
Speedway coming up this weekend and also
the book is called racing to the finish
my story Dale jr. candidly shares his
recent experiences in its out October
16th have fun this weekend oh I will and
it's great to see you and our best to a
me and your daughter and happy for you
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]